charles is now king a role he's been
preparing for for most of his life in
fact he's been the longest serving heir
to the throne in british history so what
do we know about charles and what can we
expect from him as king
era's presumptive to the throne our son
had been born
charles was born in 1948 as the eldest
son of princess elizabeth and prince
philip the duke of edinburgh when he was
just three years old his mother became
queen and he became heir to the british
throne
[Music]
he was just four at his mother's
coronation
during his early years charles sometimes
didn't see very much of his parents
because they're busy working schedules
in 1954 when charles was five his
parents went away for over six months on
a royal tour of 13 commonwealth nations
his grandmother the queen mother looked
after him and his sister during this
time and he was very close to her
when he was nine years old charles was
given that title of prince of wales a
title that's often given to the eldest
son of the monarch his investiture then
took place years later in 1969 at
carnarvon castle in wales i
charles prince of wales
will become your liege man of life
the event was watched by millions of
people on television and attracted a
large crowd in carnarvon
but there was some hostility to the
event among welsh nationalists who held
up signs in welsh that read charlie go
home
in the ceremony charles gave an address
in both english and welsh and his sense
of duty was emphasized
[Music]
during his time as the prince of wales
charles was outspoken on a number of
issues including farming urban planning
wildlife conservation and herbal
medicine
i
shudder to think of the shattered world
both on land and below the sea
we will leave our grandchild our
children and our grandchildren so many
people and communities are already
suffering
seriously from the increasingly dire
impacts of climate change what i've been
trying to say all these years is
you don't wait until it's a total
disaster before you do something notedly
he's always been vocal on the topic of
climate change and spent much of his
life campaigning for businesses and
governments to take more notice of
environmental issues
it's an attitude that he's passed on to
his sons william and harry who also
speak out about the issues important to
them
if we take too long about this we will
lose many of the precious things we care
about if charles continues to share his
views he'll be a very different kind of
monarch from his mother queen elizabeth
ii was famously discreet when it came to
anything topical or political and always
remained neutral now prince charles in
the past did say that he won't be a
meddling monarch but whether or not
he'll be as discreet as his mother we'll
have to wait and see
in his twenties charles had a playboy
reputation and was linked with a number
of women
but it was camilla parker-bowles who the
prince formed a deep connection with
due to her relationship with andrew
parker-bowles however charles was
advised against the match and married
lady diana spencer in 1981
a kiss which receives a war of approval
from the crowd
the royal couple raised two sons but
their relationship didn't last
and after finalizing their divorce in
1996
princess diana died in a car accident a
year later
in the years that followed charles began
the process of legitimizing his
relationship with camilla some breaking
news uh this morning coming to us that
it's been reported that uh prince
charles and camilla parker-bowles are to
marry i think a lot of them both because
it's it's about time that british
charles has a bit of happiness in his
life the pair married in 2005 in a civil
ceremony which the queen did not attend
but she did however go to the reception
afterwards
[Music]
charles has long been reported to desire
a slim down monarchy so it's likely
he'll maintain a small circle of senior
royals
we can probably expect to see a
continuation of prince william and
catherine's busy schedule of royal
duties as a show of family support will
be essential for the new king
the challenge for charles in the first
few years of his reign is to live up the
reputation of his mother queen elizabeth
ii who was britain's longest reigning
monarch he takes on the role of
sovereign much later in life she was
only 25 years old he instead is the
oldest british monarch to ever take the
throne
you